Hello, everyone.
My name is Martin Cousins.
I'm going to be your instructor for this course,
Introduction into Gameplay in Unreal Engine for Programmers
for Unreal 5.5.
This is a follow-on from the first course
that we did, which was Introduction to Unreal.
Quite obviously from the title,
we're going to focus more on the gameplay
aspects of the engine right now.
So just covering what we're actually
going to go over in the duration of this course,
we've got to do a quick recap of a little bit of what
we covered towards the end of our first course,
just talking a bit about how the fundamental types in the engine.
Then we're going to go more on to the first entry
point for key classes relating to the player
and some of the gameplay framework,
it would officially be called, that's involved there.
Going to move on from that a little bit
and broaden that out a little bit
to talk about game world and the flow that
goes on when you start a game.
Then we're going to talk about animation and inputs,
both obviously very relevant for gameplay code.
And then we're going to finish off
with a couple of sections about just general coding concepts
that are important to be aware of.
You'll probably have encountered things
like this in other domains, but just how Unreal
works with these things.
So that's delegates and events, serialization,
programming subsystems, which is a more Unreal-specific thing
to be aware of, and then just some of the libraries available
to you that can just provide some out-of-the-box functionality
to make things a little bit quicker.
So first off, a little bit of a recap
of what we covered in our last session.
So the fundamental classes on the absolute most base level
on Unreal, we start with UObject.
We'll get into each of these in a little bit,
but we've got UObject.
Inheriting from that, we have actor and actor component.
And then inheriting from that, we have scene component.
We'll go into a little bit more detail.
UObject is the base class for all our other Unreal
classes.
It's the entry point for reflection.
It's got no physical representation in world,
so most objects that inherit directly from UObject
are kind of intended to be data only.
They have no inbuilt tick functionality,
tick being the updates.
If your game is running 60 times a second,
your tick would be called 60 times a second.
And UObjects have no inbuilt tick functionality.
When you're spawning UObject, you
have to provide it with an outer, which
is the thing that owns it.
If you don't provide an outer,
then we use the transient package,
which is essentially things that are not saved.
So it's a kind of temporary transient object
that exists for probably the duration of a level.
UObjects can support networking, but it's not.
You need to do some kind of additional layers
of functionality.
So if you're intending on doing networking,
UObjects might not always be your first protocol
or shouldn't necessarily be always your first protocol.
And what we gave an example of in our last session
was just a data asset, which is quite a typical way
to use a UObject, which is say
we're trying to define an explosion,
we might have a UObject that has some data that kind of groups
that data together in a kind of editor friendly way.
So we might have a particle explosion and a radius,
and we use all of those to define an explosion.
Then we use that later elsewhere.
Actor inherits from UObject.
And this is kind of another big branching point for the engine
where a lot of things then extend from Actor.
That covers a lot of the gameplay functionality
we'll inherit from Actor.
Unlike UObjects, Actors do provide kind of easy functionality
for replication and connecting between client and server.
So it's whereas you should be a little bit more considerate
when you're trying to implement networked UObjects.
Once you're at the Actor level, it's a lot simpler.
We talked a little bit about this in the last session,
but when things inherit from the UObjects,
they start with this prefix U,
when they inherit from Actor and downwards from that,
they start with the prefix A,
and that is hard coded into Unreal.
You'll get compile complaints
if you're not obeying that naming convention.
The other thing about Actors,
which you can kind of see from the display here,
is that Actors are intended to utilize
a kind of component architecture.
So an Actor might inherit
and implement a lot of functionality itself,
but they are also intended to utilize
this kind of modular framework of components
so that it's easy to import kind of similar sets
of functionality between multiple Actors.
Again, referencing our last talk,
we had the explosive barrel, which was our example Actor.
And as you can see, that utilizes several components.
We've got a scene component, which is our scene route.
I'll talk a little bit more about that again in a second.
Static mesh Actor, explosion component,
which is our custom component that we made,
and then just some variables.
So Actors can implement their own functionality,
but they're best used as kind of ways
to combine sets of functionality through components.
Components, again, we've already covered a little bit,
but they are essentially our modular building block.
So, you know, typical out of the box examples
would be a collision component or a mesh component.
So if you want to be able to visualize something
or provide collision,
those are really, really obvious examples.
Another one I can think of off the top of my head
is something that provides just pure functionality,
something like a path following component,
or I think there's a component
just to make things spin on the spot.
If you just need, I don't know,
a display in a gallery that just spins,
there's a component for that.
It provides this functionality in a portable way
that you can easily chop and change it
and put it on different Actors.
There is a relatively strict relationship
between components and Actors
in that components can't exist without Actors.
Actors contain their components
and that kind of, it's not a one-to-one relationship
because an Actor can have many components,
but a current component cannot exist without an Actor.
Yeah, and essentially they provide
that kind of back and forth communication between them.
Components are aware of the Actor that owns them
and the Actor is aware of the components that it has,
which hence what this blue arrow is there
to kind of communicate.
And they kind of step down from component
from just a plain Actor component is the scene component.
This is inherits, hence this kind of line to indicate that.
And a scene component is essentially an Actor component,
but it has physical presence in the level.
Where an Actor component can just provide functionality,
scene components also provide functionality,
but in the context of a position in world.
So when I gave the example of a collision
or a visual mesh, obviously both of those things
would have positions in world.
So both of those things would actually inherit
from a scene component.
Actors also require, at least at the blueprint level,
require at least one scene component,
which is referred to as the root component.
And when you ask an Actor,
what is your location or rotation of world?
Actually that Actor doesn't innately
have a location and rotation.
What you're actually asking is what are the,
is the location and rotation
of that Actor's root component.
They can only have one root component
and then their other components
are attached to that component.
And scene components have this kind of hierarchical,
unlike Actor components,
which are kind of just slotted in,
scene components have a hierarchy between them.
So you can child them to each other
and all scene components of an Actor
are childed to the root component.
So that about covers our kind of fundamentals.
Again, if you want to go into any more detail,
any of that, you can go into our previous talk,
but now let's talk a little bit more
about the kind of the key classes
relating to the player.
So once we get to this level,
we've got quite a bit of a more complex
web of relationships to be aware of,
hence the kind of slightly possibly overwhelming graph.
Again, just to highlight what all these visuals mean,
we have these kind of solid white lines.
This is just to kind of demonstrate inheritance
and the dotted white lines is just indicating,
obviously there are a lot more classes
that inherit from Actor.
There are a lot more classes that inherit from Pawn
and so on and so forth.
But this is the kind of things
we're going to go into right now.
These are the kind of relationships
we need to be concerned about.
We'll zoom into each of these as we go along
and talk a little bit more about them,
but this is just kind of an overview
of all the things we're going to be covering.
So we already talked about Actor,
but once we're at the player level,
one of the first things to talk about is a Pawn.
A Pawn is essentially a base class of any Actor
that can be possessed.
That is either be by a player or an AI.
Possess is the term for this thing
has something controlling it.
A Pawn is the physical representation of a player and agent.
So it exists in world.
Typically when you have a playable character,
it would be a Pawn.
And it's kind of a very basic plain canvas.
It doesn't innately have much in the way
of movement capability.
It doesn't have collision.
It has no visuals.
A basic Pawn has very, very little in it.
Just this functionality to be controlled.
Pawns have a one-to-one relationship with a controller.
Hence this kind of blue arrow here.
Pawns are aware of the thing that controls them,
which is a controller, which we'll touch on in a second.
And controllers are aware of the Pawn they're controlling.
Pawns aren't assumed to be humanoid.
They could be anything.
They could be abstract.
They do have a location in world,
but you could have a Pawn that represents a mini game.
And it's kind of like the thing
that's pulling all your input together.
You could have a Pawn that represents a flying drone
or something like that.
It's not inherently a character
with two legs running around kind of thing.
It's also worth touching on the fact
that Actors themselves can consume input
and have their transform manipulated.
So that is not unique to Pawn,
but it is facilitated more strongly within Pawn.
So if you are thinking about controlling something,
Pawn should be your starting point.
It's Actors you can listen for input,
but it requires a bit more setup
and that should be for special cases really.
So coming down from the Pawn level,
we have two more classes.
We have Default Pawn and Spectator Pawn.
Default Pawn is not inherited from
in other classes from the game.
It's only into Spectator Pawn.
So it should not be the base class
for when you're intending to make your own.
It's just the kind of engine Default Pawn.
So if you're in a random level
and you don't have anything playable
and you just click play,
I'm currently playing as the Default Pawn now.
It essentially provides some basic movement functionality.
It does have a collision.
It's got no gravity.
It's kind of a flying style movement
and it's bound to input.
So by default, you can use WASD
and jumping to kind of move up.
And it just provides some really,
really basic fundamental functionality.
Spectator Pawn inherits from Default Pawn
and therefore brings along a lot of the same functionality.
Actually what the Spectator Pawn does
is replace the movement component that it uses.
The Spectator Pawn's movement component
is primarily there to add in some extra functionality
for the ability to possibly ignore time dilation
if you don't want slow-mo to affect it.
And also just to remove the concept of a mesh
because the spectators are meant to be abstract.
A spectator obviously being for
at the end of a match if your character has died
and you still want to move around the space,
that's the kind of assumption
for why the Spectator Pawn exists.
Obviously if you want to implement your own,
you can absolutely do that.
So going back up that chain slightly,
the other class that we have out of the box
inheriting from Pawn that we need to talk about
is the Character.
Character is essentially a shortcut class.
You don't need to use it,
but essentially what Epic realized
was the vast majority of the time
when we are making games
or if we've got a playable character,
it is typically an upright,
probably capsule-like shape
and we would need movement,
we would need visual mesh and we would need collision.
So the character essentially just provides
all of that stuff out of the box.
It comes with a collision component,
it comes with a skeletal mesh component
because most of the time our characters are animated
and it also comes with movement functionality
baked into it.
It has this special relationship
with a unique kind of movement component
called a character movement component,
which we'll get into in a moment.
But typically when you're making a human-like
or humanoid character,
a character might as well be your starting point
because it just provides a bunch of functionality for you.
The character movement component is a specialized form
of the Pawn movement component
and it's linked quite tightly with the character.
So every time you pull in a character class,
it's always going to pull in
a character movement component with it
and the character movement component
depends on a character existing.
It expects to be implementing movement
for a character class.
The movement component provides
a whole bunch of functionality.
It's first and foremost,
it's got networking already baked into it,
meaning that if you just instantly create
a networked multiplayer game and you're using characters,
that will mean you've already got your positions
and rotations being communicated
between the server and client.
And it means that you've got client-side prediction,
meaning that you're going to get
a less aggressive reconciliation
between your server and your client.
It accounts for several different modes of moving.
So we have walking, running, falling, swimming, and flying.
And each of these is kind of handled distinctly
within the code.
So if you need to kind of investigate
or inject functionality into these classes,
they're all kind of broken up into separate sections.
You can also add in additional movement modes.
So if you want to add in
your own custom new movement mode
that doesn't fall under any of the preexisting categories,
you can do that.
That being said, the character movement component
isn't marked as blueprintable,
so you can't make blueprints that inherit
from the character movement component by default,
unless you can go and edit the engine code yourself.
And what that means is that if you do want
to kind of blueprint your own custom movement mode,
the way that's actually best to do that
is on the character blueprint itself.
So because the character
and the character movement component are so tightly linked,
quite a lot of the movement functionality
can be accessed through the character class.
And so the update custom movement event
on the character blueprint itself would be getting called,
and that's the point where you can inject
any kind of custom movement functionality that you need.
The other thing to kind of bear in mind
is that as character is, you know,
inherently got a capsule, an upright standing capsule,
character movement component is expecting you
to make an upright vertically aligned character.
So if you're not doing something like that
and you want something more like a,
maybe like, I don't know, something quadrupedal,
like a dog or a cat character
and the character movement component
might not be completely suitable for that.
So stepping all the way back up the chain now
up to actor and inheriting from that,
we have controllers.
We've touched on in this a little bit already,
but controllers are essentially
where a pawn is the thing that gets controlled.
A controller is the thing that does the controlling.
So where a pawn represents
the kind of physical object in world,
controller represents a little bit more
like that object's mind.
It has no physical actor.
It does technically have a position in world.
Like if you started play, if I played a level
and you could actually see that I do have a,
there are controllers actually in my level
and they do actually have a location,
but for the most part,
their transform is somewhat irrelevant.
They don't have any kind of collision
or visual representation.
The main purpose for a controller is to possess a pawn.
It has a one-to-one relationship with a pawn.
So a pawn can only be controlled by one controller.
Really it's intended that controllers
only control one pawn.
Obviously in certain situations and certain game setups
that might not be completely suitable,
but the standard intent is for a controller
to control a single pawn
and a pawn to be controlled by a single controller.
Controllers also get informed about a lot of events
and notifications about the pawns they're controlling,
if they possess it, if they stop possessing it
and many other things.
The other thing is that
none of the transform functionalities
are exposed in native in C++.
So again, you're really not intended to manipulate
the location and rotation of the controller.
One thing to talk about very briefly though,
is that as you could see
when I was quickly demonstrating there,
if at runtime you have your controller selected,
you will be able to see that our rotation is changing
as we move our viewer around.
This is kind of a slightly more in depth,
but essentially when you are controlling a pawn,
you have a concept called the control rotation.
And that is vaguely meant a way,
a default way of representing
what is the kind of intent direction of this pawn.
And that might be the player's view rotation.
It might be the direction that an AI is moving in.
And that is when you're talking about
that control rotation,
that is actually the rotation of the controller.
So whilst for the most part,
you don't need to be editing these things,
the rotation of the controller
does actually have some meaning,
which is why you see updating in runtime.
So inheriting from controllers themselves,
we have two different classes.
Unlike these other classes, pawn and actor,
which might have a lot of things inheriting from them,
controller is specifically only inherited
by these two types.
You could inherit from it yourself,
but a controller is an abstract class
and player controller and AI controller,
where we actually kind of get into things
that you might actually see getting spawned in your game.
So a player controller represents the human player's will.
You would have a player controller exist
for every human player in your game.
So if you had a local co-op game
and you had four players,
you would expect to have four player controllers
spawned in your level.
They essentially act as a centralizing point
for your player's camera and input.
Both of these systems are actually handled
by other systems under the hood.
There's something called the player camera manager
and the player input components,
which they kind of really handle
each of those things directly,
but the player controller gives you a way
to interface with both of those things.
Player controllers also persist
throughout the duration of a world.
That's true of controllers in general,
but typically when you start a level,
your players would already exist.
There is functionality to spawn new players in,
but a player controller would exist
for the duration of a world
as long as that player exists.
The other thing we'll get onto in a moment
is the fact that the player controller exists
on the server and on the controlling client's machine.
So in a networked multiplayer scenario,
the server would have a copy of each player controller
and each client would see their own player controller,
but not others.
We'll go into more detail about that later,
but it's a thing that's worth highlighting.
So separately from that,
the other kind of branch that we can go down
is AI controllers.
Pretty self-explanatory.
This is the will of an AI entity.
So where a player controller represents a human player,
an AI controller represents some kind of AI
that would be controlling entities within the world.
Just like a player controller,
because they're a form of controller,
they can possess pawns.
And this means that you can have a pawn
that can be controlled by a player
and the exact same pawn could be controlled by an AI.
And the idea being that it's intentionally abstracted
into separate sections
so that you might be able to reuse these things,
thinking about something like a game like Unreal Tournament
or something like that.
You really have the same characters running around,
picking up guns, driving cars, shooting things.
And it might be a human controlling that entity
or it might be an AI.
So this is kind of helpful way to think about these things,
about why they might be structured the way they are.
And the way an AI controller works
is there's a set of components
that really kind of drive that logic.
We'll get into more detail in this in another session,
but just briefly to touch on it,
you have the blackboard component,
which is essentially that AI's kind of knowledge and memory.
And then you have the brain component,
which kind of performs the logic.
And that's most typically exists
in the form of the behavior tree,
but there are other classes that implement that behavior,
that kind of brain logic.
The other thing to highlight is unlike player controllers,
these only exist on the server
because Unreal is server authoritative.
It's only the server that really is managing the AI's
and then each client,
what they really get is just a replicated form
of what all the AI's are doing on the server.
So it's only the server
that needs those AI controllers to exist.